hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca on foreign again we have
some more info to talk about today as in
my last video we talked a lot about the
new reworks and the up-and-coming stuff
in the testing ground
well Ubisoft has released on their
website the all the changes that are
going to be happening so this video
right here will be showing everything
like I said I probably won't be going
over every single little itty-bitty
detail like especially the ones that I
covered in last video so if you have not
watched last video definitely go check
that it'll be linked right now on the
top right or at the end of this video
but anything that we didn't cover in
that video that is going to be covered
in this video because this information
just came out like 10 minutes ago
so anyway like the vid do enjoy guys
subscribe if you're new and let's get
started as always I will be leaving a
link to this down in the description
down below so maybe later in the future
if you do want to look this over if you
want to look this over wall we're
talking right now you can go do that so
be in the description down below but
first up we're gonna go over what
Centurion the move to gladiator then to
warlord for Centurion things that we
didn't check out was that his charged
heaven II his charge heavy opener the
maximum charge strike is now going to do
30 damage instead of 25 the charge
portion is now going to be between 300
and 500 two milliseconds instead of 200
to 600 so that window is a little bit
shorter and the guard break
invulnerability now begins at 300 m/s
before the strike and then the maximum
charge hit recovery duration from a bot
for a bound opponent is 766 milliseconds
I have no [ __ ] idea what that means
minimum charge knock-back has also been
reduced and you can no longer saw faint
in 2 GB went out of stamina pretty
charged heavy finisher maximum charge
strike can now be fainted the maximum
charge strike can now also be saw
fainted in 2 GB and then the maximum
charge hit recovery duration if re bound
opponent is 766 milliseconds this used
to be 1300 and can no longer be saw
fainted in two guard break went out of
stamina so most of the stuff we've
already have covered in the past video
for jab but can now be exited with the
cancel or faint button and it starts
around 300 milliseconds into an attack
obviously once you hit them you go right
into that strike the maximum punch now
is moving you a little bit more forward
taking that distance and the charge
portion is now 800 milliseconds as
opposed to 600 as we stated last
it's a little bit longer but you have
the ability to feint it and with the jab
you can no longer bind an opponent in
revenge activation so I do believe the
opponent is in revenge and you smack
them with a jab they should not fall to
the floor or they shouldn't stop
I believe you actually get hit and
knocked back from it now but the jab
combo the maximum punch and now moves
you forward just like with the regular
punch and the charge portion is now 800
as opposed to 600 same exact thing and
it also no longer binds an opponent in
revenge activation so jab and jab combo
is the exact same thing in terms of
changes except jab can now be canceled
and jab combo I don't think you can
cancel Eagle Talon now does a whopping
45 damage as opposed to 35 which is
really nice and then we talked about the
zone attack the second and third strike
are going to be able to be fainted
faints will be costing 10 stamina each
strike and I'll cost 20 stamina and then
damage from them is going to be 17
damage 17 damage 17 damage as opposed to
25 25 25 you'll also be moving a little
bit farther when you do this and it now
has a medium hit reactionist to post a
heavy medium hit reaction is a little
bit less in terms of the heavy with the
stun recovery but you can still Ledge
them with it to give you an idea if a
move has a light hit recovery they will
not be able to be ledged medium hit
recovery and heavy hit recovery have the
option to Ledge that person but the
difference between heavy and medium is
the longer that person stays and has to
recover from that move to be able to use
their guard again we've already went
over his light attacks but just a quick
refresher his light attack opener is now
17 damage as opposed to 15 the second
light attack strike and the third light
attack strike are now 500 milliseconds
they used to be 600 and 700 so they're
gonna be a little bit faster and then
the second and third chain lights are
gonna do 17 damage as opposed to 12 so a
little bit faster and does a bit more
damage which is nice
recoveries from any light attack are now
a hundred milliseconds later so a little
bit longer in the recovery and there's a
bug fix for the light attacks that
allows the out of lock attacks they
should not have the same recovery
timings used to not have this before it
was all very buggy but that is not gonna
be there for parry counters heavy
finishers will no longer be guaranteed
Legion kick can also be dodged a new
link allows a guaranteed second light in
the chain
and the perry counter will also push the
opponent less far away along for a
better heavy finisher mixup so it seems
like the head the perry counter isn't
going to be as useful as it used to be
but maybe this is to avoid the the
obvious cutscene that Centurion had for
the quick throw quick throw is going to
be completely removed entirely and
replaced by the same jab after a heavy
attack so definitely be on the lookout
for that and for the throw in general
Centurions kick and heavy finisher are
now launched 200 milliseconds later and
the opponent unbalance starts at about a
hundred milliseconds earlier for the
bug-fix interion no longer has super
armor during the end of the throw like a
lot of other characters and then this
last one is this weird little bug fix
with lions ward this just improved the
synchronization between the two fighters
nothing really crazy there overall not
too bad of a rework and now I'm not a
Centurion player I've maybe put in like
maybe one rep at least in this character
so I don't really have a giant idea like
I don't really have a the greatest
expertise on what exactly is happening I
will have a lot more with gladiator
which we'll get into in a second but as
for Centurion let me know any Centuria
means let me know what you guys think
about in the comments below but see here
comes the big issue in a sense gladiator
and warlord according to this document
here this post on the for honor website
at this website and this post is
supposed to be taken as fact improving
that every single thing in here is going
to be in the testing grounds that's a
bit of a problem because nothing had
changed from warlord and gladiator from
the video we talked about as I stated if
you do want to see all of those in what
I talked about definitely click the
video at the end of this video it'll be
the one that I just uploaded about an
hour ago
basically nothing had changed all
basically what we heard from gladiator
and warlord those characters are going
to beginning exactly what we heard
Centurion was the only one that didn't
go into such fine detail and that to a
degree bothers me I feel like gladiator
can do so much with the availability to
have a heavy leg combo his buckler hit
into heavy is not guaranteed I believe
that might be called cheap shot or
Sucker Punch one of the whatever one is
the follow-up heavy that one isn't
guaranteed in his very bad skewer of
course is a nice change but it still
doesn't take out of the fact that hyper
armor can bounce right off of skewer and
do about
to damage the toast that buff is always
nice I would have just got rid of the
light chains in general and kept the one
that has four lights but that's just me
I feel like once again a heavy like
combo would have been great they didn't
even change the zone a lot of people
have been bitching about how the zone is
really good and obviously that might
need a nerf and they don't even change
that so hopefully with this stuff and a
lot of talking on the survey that we can
change this because as for me in my
opinion the gladiator rework is really
not that great honestly the change the
stance didn't change you know getting
him to normalize with all the assassins
is amazing and I will be forever
grateful for that but just adding that
is not going to help him and these other
changes aren't really huge monumental
changes that can really help this
character rise up in the tier list
because honestly if he's not gonna be
bottom I think this might raise him to
maybe being like middle and that's
really not gonna be that great
and same with warlord that's just my
opinion let me know what you guys think
about this in the comments below like I
said I was gonna put this in my past
video in the first one that I made but
this stuff came out right after I
uploaded mine so I have to do a little
bit of a secondary video but of course
all the info is there if you do want to
use this you guys can like both these
videos keep it in a playlist you know
check the link in the description yeah
guys leave the VP do enjoy guys
subscribe if you're new I cover the
information inside a foreigner that
being the balance changes they hear
updates the Patricks and the leaks if
you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
Warner I never miss out on an update
that please do subscribe the channel
the guys have a great I think for
watching the video peace out and let me
know what you guys think about these new
changes and stuff
[Music]